even superheroes aren't immune to being
played by the wrong person that being
said these Infamous casting decisions
didn't exactly make for riveting Cinema
along with incoherent tone and
inconsistent pacing viewers of Ridley
Scott's house of Gucci found themselves
irritated by Jared Leto's portrayal of
Paolo Gucci the aspiring but untalented
designer son of company chairman Aldo
Gucci with his cartoonish performance
and rather insulting caricature of an
Italian accent Leto's Paulo stood to be
the black sheep of not just the Gucci
family in the story but also of the
biographical crime film itself any
attempts to strike a serious tone were
thwarted by Leto's repeated squeals that
border on a Super Mario impression stop
you're going to make me you don't need
to make me cry Tom Ford a filmmaker and
former Gucci designer had his own
critique of the movie and the
performances it featured especially
lettos having personally known some of
the main characters depicted in the film
including Paolo Gucci Ford commented
Leto's Brilliance as an actor is
literally buried under latex Prosthetics
Paolo whom I met on several occasions
was indeed eccentric and did some wacky
things but his overall demeanor was
certainly not like the crazed character
of letters Performance Ford likened the
Leto's efforts to a Saturday Night Live
sketch but still gave plenty of praise
to his co-stars Lady Gaga and Adam
Driver
while he may have gotten his act
together when he reprized the character
in Spider-Man no way home Jaime Fox's
first appearance as Electro in The
Amazing Spider-Man 2 was pretty rough to
say the least considering that the 2014
Spider-Man sequel was globally dubbed as
rise of Electro you would expect a
formidable primary antagonist whose
relevance in the plot reflects the
inclusion of their name in the movie's
title instead Fox's Max Dylan turned out
to be a caricature of the neglected nerd
whose turn to villainy is motivated by
the fact that Spider-Man didn't remember
his name problematic character
motivation and controversial blue
redesign aside Fox's performance as the
overlooked but brilliant engineer turned
supervillain seems to elicit more laughs
than sympathy this could have been fixed
with a different casting decision as the
effortlessly cool Fox didn't do the best
job coming across like a total dork
fortunately the actor had the
opportunity to take Electro in a New
Direction in Spider-Man no way home
where he comes across as much more
charismatic and likable
the 2003 superhero film Daredevil did no
favors for anyone involved in its
production including lead star Ben
Affleck for him Daredevil was just one
of three movies that year that earned
him the golden raspberry award for worst
actor the other two being Gili and
paycheck fans and critics lambasted
Affleck for his lackluster acting and
argued that he was miscast for the role
of Matt Murdock although the hero of
Hell's Kitchen is known to be charming
and charismatic in the comics Affleck's
version comes across as more cocky and
creepy you're holding back
stop
the reception towards the film and its
portrayal of The Man Without Fear led to
Affleck refusing any costume roles for a
decade it was only in 2013 that Affleck
was announced to be the new version of
The Dark Knight in Zack Snyder's Batman
v Superman dawn of Justice and its
follow-ups in the DC extended Universe
over the years Affleck has made it
abundantly clear how much he resents
Daredevil and his involvement in the
film after accepting the role of Bruce
Wayne Affleck told Time Magazine of his
decision part of it was I wanted for
once to get one of these movies and do
it right to do a good version I hate
Daredevils so much regardless Daredevil
is still a beloved character but we
mostly have Charlie Cox to thank for
that a lot of people were underwhelmed
when Jai Courtney and Emilia Clarke were
announced to play Kyle Reese and Sarah
Connor in the 2015 franchise reboot
Terminator Genesis after all the two
actors had quite big shoes to fill
following up the acclaimed performances
of Michael bean and Anton Yelchin as
Kyle and Linda Hamilton as Sarah in
previous Terminator movies sure enough
the film received mixed reviews not just
for its plot but for its casting and
performances as well fans and critics
had a lot to say about Courtney's Bland
acting with many claiming that his bulky
physique wasn't helping sell the idea
that his character grew up in a
post-apocalyptic Wasteland similarly
Clark's youthful looks simply didn't
make sense for Sarah Connor not to
mention the absolute lack of Chemistry
Between the two actors who briefly
engage in on-screen romance
unsurprisingly Clark revealed that she
did not have a good time and regrets
filming Terminator Genesis citing
various behind the scenes incidents that
made her rather relieved when production
kept unfortunately for director Josh
trank and his cast the 2015 Fantastic
Four reboot ended up being one of those
movies where the behind the scenes drama
is much more interesting than the film
itself the making of the critical and
Commercial disaster was a total mess and
tranq found himself clashing not just
with Executives at Fox but with some of
the core cast members as well according
to Entertainment Weekly Kate Mara wasn't
trink's original choice to play Sue
storm but after the studio overruled his
preferences shrink allegedly mistreated
Mara on set he didn't have a good
relationship with Reed Richards actor
Miles Teller either perhaps this hostile
environment led to the actor's
performances being devoid of chemistry
while Michael B Jordan's natural
Charisma made him a solid fit for the
fun-loving Johnny Storm his casting was
criticized by some for being a poor
attempt at diversifying the cast
especially since Johnny's sister Sue is
played by a white woman though in the
film it is mentioned that Sue storm was
adopted even Jamie Bell's casting as Ben
Grimm came with scrutiny as the actors 5
feet 7 inch stature is a far cry from
the character's massive frame even
before turning into the thing all in all
considering the lousy set experiences of
the actors and crew it's for the best
that any prospects of sequels were
promptly canned does it hurt
I'm used to it when Mamma Mia danced
into theaters in 2008 audiences loved
the vibrant musical numbers the jolly
and campy tone and the exuberant
characters placed in the fictional Greek
island of kalokairi the only aspect of
the film that didn't work you guessed it
Pierce Brosnan Brosnan makes for a fine
addition to the ensemble cast of the
Abba musical but when he sings Let's
just say he's not as appealing to the
ears as he is to the eyes it's only
natural that having an actor with no
singing expertise perform in a musical
movie would draw some iron especially
when they're up against the
inexperienced yet melodic voices of
Meryl Streep and Christine baransky the
former James Bond singing was brutally
lambasted by critics who described his
Renditions of SOS and when all is said
and done as some of the worst in movie
history while Brosnan received the
Razzie award for worst supporting actor
that didn't stop him from returning to
the 2018 sequel Mamma Mia here we go
again he's even said that he'd be down
to return for potential third film
telling Good Morning America it's
criminal how much fun you have on that
movie I think everybody would be in
the star-studded cast of 2019's cats
wasn't what made the movie so awful it
was probably doomed from the start
instead the casting decisions for the
Andrew Lloyd Webber adaptation turned
into a complete disaster for each
actor's career this feline train wreck
features comedic actors like James
Corden and Rebel Wilson rapper Jason
Derulo and singers Taylor Swift and
Jennifer Hudson alongside renowned
thespians like Dame Judy Dench Idris
Elba and Sir Ian McKellen everyone
brings their talents to the table
McKellen's acting chops Hudson's voice
corden's something but it's all hidden
behind some of the most unsettling CGI
that Hollywood has to offer the bizarre
visual effects make cats a frightening
viewing experience and the feeble
attempts at humor from Wilson and Corden
do nothing to cover up their lack of
singing ability right well that's not
going to work is it apparently cat's
Creator and composer Andrew Lloyd Webber
hated corden's performance in the film
indirectly hinting that the comedian's
portrayal a fat cat Buster for Jones was
unfunny while dinch Elba and McKellen
all do their best many critics agree
that Swift was the only redeeming cast
member an interesting tidbit considering
her lack of experience as an actor
Kristen Stewart is an esteemed actress
nowadays with an Oscar nomination for a
portrayal of Princess Diana in 2021
Spencer however this wasn't always the
case as the performer found herself
mocked for her monotone performances
during her Twilight years the ridicule
wasn't limited to the vampiric Love
Story either Stewart found herself
criticized yet again when she took on
the titular role of Snow White in Snow
White and the Huntsman in this 2012
action fantasy Stewart's performance was
yet again lambasted for her limited
range of facial expressions leading some
viewers to believe that her involvement
supposedly ruined the movie reviewer
Scott foundis a film comment put it well
when he wrote Stuart Snow White
meanwhile pouts her lips bats her
bedroom eyes and scarcely seems to have
more in her mind than who might take her
to the senior prom let alone the destiny
of an entire Kingdom Stewart won the
golden raspberry award for worst actress
that year after which the actress chose
to focus on Independent films instead of
Studio franchises she was conspicuously
absent from the 2016 sequel the Huntsman
Winter's War which was partially brought
on by her scandalous affair during the
production of the first film with wedded
director Rupert Sanders
Martin scorsese's 2002 historical epic
Gangs of New York received positive
reviews and garnered 10 nominations at
the Oscars including best picture and
best actor for Daniel Day-Lewis none of
those nominations were for Cameron Diaz
though as most movie Buffs concur that
her performance sadly detracts from the
film's overall greatness Diaz plays
Jenny Everdeen an Irish pickpocket Who
falls in love with Leonardo DiCaprio's
gangster Amsterdam ballad it's hard to
buy into the 19th century setting of the
film when Diaz's accent and DiCaprio's 2
to some extent keeps faltering making it
impossible to stay invested in her
performance don't tell me you're angry
with me no I'm through with you viewers
found the nearly three-hour long movie
modeled enough with various themes as it
is and many believe that the romance
subplot between Jenny and Amsterdam felt
unnecessary Diaz wasn't even scorsese's
ideal choice for the part now disgrace
producer Harvey Weinstein compelled the
director to choose Diaz over other
actresses including Sarah Pali and Sarah
Michelle gella
foreign
[Music]